nous sommes sur l'exploitation que j'ai
repris il ya à peu près une année mon
entreprise s'appelle marc goc
margouillats ben parce que c'est un des
emblèmes du la réunion le cops parce que
j'élève des coques et les deux réunis ça
donnait un animal qui s'appelle comme ça
hein margotte caisse et sympathique à
regarder
cette exploitation se constitue de sept
bâtiments installés sur 23 mille mètres
carrés où je produis que des poulets et
coques fermiers c'est que des animaux
qui sont élevées en plein air qui rentre
dans les bâtiments s'ils le souhaitent
avec un libre-service en eau et en
aliments je suis plus proche de
l'agriculture raisonnée et donc
j'abandonne petit à petit la molécule de
synthèse ou médicaments et je suis
maintenant orientée sur un produit de
type naturelles et les animaux en fait
nous rendions ce qu'ils sont très très
calme avec des produits diététiques
je ne manque pour particuliers c'est à
dire que j'ai quand même une petite
exploitation avant de reprendre la
société j'ai eu certain nombre de mois
de chômage car le dossier avait été
assez long et ses périodes de chômages
m'a permis de passer mon diplôme
agricole à saint joseph
et d'enchaîner après avec
l'administratif qui était assez
conséquent pour une reprise de ce type
de société est un parcours de combattant
a été long trois grandes années à force
à force de vouloir et de vouloir savoir
son entreprise et a réussi donc
maintenant c'est que du beau et que du
bon en manger pour les décrire mon
objectif dans les prochains jours ou
semaines ce serait d'embaucher quelqu'un
qui est déjà me me donner un coup de
main à titre amical ça va être la
première embauche que je vais donc créé
avec quelqu'un que pas été trop aidé
dans la ville ont plutôt défavorisé donc
ça va être une double satisfaction
d'aider quelqu'un ici
déterminé le laboratoire ce qu'on
appelle une tuerie dont pour rentrer
dans les normes
j'ai déjà la moitié du de la tuerie
qu'est fabriqué donc l'autre moitié
viendra avec le temps l'argent notamment
et je voulais profiter de cette
interview pour dire à tous les futurs
créateurs d'entreprise il faut jamais
rien lâcher parce que les dossiers sont
tellement dure je les invite à toujours
résisté parce que l'aboutissement sera
vraiment très positif pour don ne
lâchait rien et continuer
j'ai travaillé toute ma vie pour avoir
une carrière et un salaire maintenant
mais en fait j'ai toujours été attiré
par l'agricole moi c'est mon c'est noël
avant l'heure en fait c'était mon jouet
mais bon ça a été assez dur de la voix
mais c'est c'est l'aboutissement d'un
rêve en salle